when's the next equalizer
I'm like why do you guys like that movie
so much those people you took the money
from maybe you should give it back why
would we do that he says because you get
the guys we want to get
hurt more than the beaten and the first
one for Carl just wants to live a simple
life hey we better know what you did
before you got here I was a pip you know
like Gladys Knight in the picture he's a
reluctant Destroyer I promise I would
never go back to being that person would
have been somebody does something
unspeakable give me that ring please
it's okay Jenny you do something about
it he's helping the Innocence he's
helping those that can't help themselves
I mean about a girl it's a personal
violence
up close or you Jackie Chan
in the beginning of equalizer 2 Robert
McCall is trying to find his Humanity
within other people thought you were
retired oh I am like you're dead the
difference is it's much more personal
they killed my friend this mistake to go
to war with him
they're going to war with me
is very different than the first two
films because of these people I'm
beginning to understand real peace that
made sense from a call to find a home
there in Italy I like this place you
can't take that from me but the mafia
that can take anything I want this is
your home that's a big Thrift whatever
it is you and your friends do do it
somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
helping those who can't help themselves
handing out Justice his way he's going
through an eternal battle you seem like
a man who understands violence
has he gone too far police found
multiple dead bodies on that farm in
Sicily to kill him
do I look like a killer
[Music]